let's get to the most important bag
which is the mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com on fridays we will
feature
some but not nearly all i mean listen we
get thousands of messages a week we will
feature some
of the messages that come in info
davidpakman.com
compliments welcome of course questions
uh prioritized
criticisms
received and then trolling more or less
ignored but not always let's start with
the first message
this one is from ben
and it is about george soros
ben says hello david
is it true that you are being funded by
george soros
i have heard that in south korea my
country
george soros and an international jewish
cabal
are trying to destroy the country by
funding mass immigration and low birth
rates
in order to achieve
world domination
is
this true
you know it's not true and there's a
couple things going on here first of all
george soros is 92 years old
i think that at this point even if at
one point he had his
heart set on global dominate domination
uh through low birth rates and all these
different things that take decades if
not longer to do
i think at this point he's probably done
with that plan he is now 92 years old
and most importantly
no
i am not funded by george soros
not funded by george soros not funded by
the dnc
not funded by whoever you think we're
funded by i'm funded by people in the
audience probably not like ben
but people in the audience who value
what we do and choose to support it paul
wrote in and says your stated opinion in
past episodes on youtube
was that you were doubtful trump would
ever be prosecuted for the crimes he's
committed in light of recent events at
various court proceedings and
particularly the stealing of classified
information
have you now revised your opinion thank
you i have and as i've said before i
would love to be wrong on this
i now believe that donald trump is
likely to be indicted
and not likely to serve even a single
day behind bars that's my current
opinion and as many of you might know if
you watch the show at all regularly i
revise my opinions as information
uh becomes available
and i think that that's a great thing to
do it's something that should be
encouraged
and i now believe trump will be indicted
no prison time
curious to hear from you your thoughts
paul wrote in about student loan
forgiveness
paul says david i know many see the
student loan relief as a good thing but
i see problems with it
i will say that i'm happy that it seems
well targeted only ten thousand dollars
to people earning under 125 thousand
my issue with it is that it's a band-aid
and it sets a precedent it may help
people with debt now but it won't
convince next year students to think
twice before taking out large loans that
they can't afford and we'll be right
back in the same place people will be
clamoring for another round of student
loan relief in five years younger
siblings will say my older sister got
relief now it's my turn this can't
become an ongoing expectation wouldn't
this money be better spent trying to
make education more affordable
for future and current students rather
than forgiving loans for people who
already agreed to pay them off for
giving the interest so the debt doesn't
keep growing but keeping the principal
is also a great idea that i've heard
others mention curious to hear your
thoughts good show yeah i've addressed
this
the student loan debt relief
won't do anything to put downward
pressure on the price of college and
university and higher education and we
need to do that the system is broken the
system is broken we i was calculating
the other day
if prices continue increasing
over the next 18 years
by the time my daughter would go to
college
the uh college that my girlfriend went
to would cost 206 000 a year right so
you're talking like 850 k for four years
is is that possible or is does that
sound like something's broken so
absolutely something needs to change and
just a little a sprinkling of student
loan debt relief isn't going to do it
and so this is two different problems
it's one problem the system is broken
but there's two different parts to it
existing debt and doing something about
the cost of college what joe biden does
does something about existing debt it
doesn't deal with the cost of college we
need at minimum free community college
if tons of people
who would go to a four-year school and
take on four years of debt say hey you
know what i'll do my first two years for
free at community college if that
happens
demand for the four-year schools will go
down and those schools will have to if
they want to increase the number of
people who are interested and willing to
go
uh they're going to have to decrease
prices that's it's one idea there's many
others
another idea which is controversial to
some is make it more difficult to get
the loans if it's more difficult to just
get a loan for 400k to go wherever you
want for whatever degree
um if it becomes more difficult that
would put downward pressure so i'm with
you 100 paul this doesn't deal with the
second issue
it only deals with the debt and we need
to be dealing with both
clint wrote in about hillary clinton i
don't know what the hell clint's talking
about here maybe you can help me figure
it out clint writes david i follow you
and listen to you regularly i have to
tell you hillary's not running in 2024.
i never said she was i worked for her
campaign in 2008 and 2016. the majority
of her staff myself included are
positioning ourselves for pete boudij
you can correct me if i'm wrong if
you're going to say anything about
hillary at least speak positive well
listen clint i will sometimes say
positive things about hillary and
sometimes i will say negative things
about hillary i will say whatever i want
about hillary on the show but in terms
of
she's not running and
speak pos i don't know what you're
talking about clint i never said hillary
was running i did do a story a couple of
months ago indicating that there are
high level
democratic party people talking about
hillary running again i didn't say it
was former you know lower level staff or
anything like that
but uh clint maybe the message was meant
for someone else i don't know
but we'll see if we can figure out about
it chris wrote in and asked is losing
better
david do you think it may be becoming a
republican strategy to lose just enough
elections to not have a majority power
in the senate but still have enough
seats to filibuster major legislation
and this could apply to the white house
in 2024 as well my point is they seem to
enjoy being able to criticize everything
democrats do and they don't really have
any policies to speak of mitch mcconnell
always talks about his main objective is
to win elections but maybe not what do
you think well i've addressed this in a
very specific way which is
republicans in 2024
want to make the case that biden should
be replaced with a republican because he
didn't get anything done
and so
republicans want to ensure
that biden and democrats don't get
anything done and a great way to do that
is to have divided congress democrats
controlling the senate and republicans
controlling the house it's a great way
for
in the lead up to the 24 election
republicans to be able to say look
they've had the white house for four
years they've had the senate for four
years
and when's the last time they got
anything done and of course there would
be that two-year stretch where nothing
gets done
because republicans control the house
so i don't know about the bigger picture
chris of just
never get anything done and
but i think in the immediate that's
exactly their goal with joe biden and
democrats over the next two years
um terry wrote in and said
you messaged me and i'm gonna keep doing
this for as long as i have to terry said
david i was watching your youtube show
last night
and i got two messages that appeared to
be from you it was whatsapp and it said
write me
i don't use whatsapp i've never twitted
and i certainly have never instagram
crackered anything
keep on rocking brother yeah so listen
i am not trying to dm or whatsapp
anybody in the audience okay there are
rampant scammers on our youtube channel
and they will put my face imagine that
this face they put my face as their
profile image and they respond to people
in the comments and they say hey i'd
love to chat with you directly please
whatsapp me dm me hear this that the
other thing and it's a scam they want to
steal your money okay
we report them to youtube as fast as we
can
you can report them to youtube say that
they are impersonating uh me
and youtube will ban them but it's like
whack-a-mole okay so i'm not trying to
contact anyone
the only time i am in touch with viewers
is when they call in when we take calls
all right so
not me don't fall for it
jeffrey asks should we leave the country
this is a sad situation
jeffrey says i've been concerned for a
while now that if an autocrat is elected
in 24
it may be time to really consider
leaving the us and moving to a country
that has a stable democracy
through my work i could get a visa in a
scandinavian country and or my wife has
dual citizenship in australia i think
it's important for my children to live
in a safe free country and i'm concerned
we could be seeing the end of such a
country here in the u.s
leaving the country has always seemed
like a drastic step to me but it seems
it's becoming more of a reality what do
you think well you know every time this
comes up people get mad at me and they
say david
you're dripping with privilege when you
talk about this
it is a reality
that i was born in argentina
so if i needed to go to another country
i could go back to argentina it's and by
the way if you look at the economic
situation and who's in power right now
down there it's it's no it's no dream to
be down there okay
but it's something all right
as an individual of the jewish
persuasion
as who was it that said that i don't
remember anyway i'm jewish
i could go through a process i believe
it takes a year or two to get
citizenship in israel
and yes because my family is originally
from western europe and fled right
before the holocaust poland has a
program
where i could request citizenship
because my grandfather was from poland
i'm working on it i still don't have the
documents i need to do that so yeah i'm
i'm working on a backup plan for sure
now am i in this like i'm moving to
canada if desantis wins in 24. now first
of all it's really hard to move to
canada i don't know how many of you have
looked into it but um no i'm not saying
that but what i would say jeffrey is
you are going to do
what is best for your family
and so
i would have the plan in place why not
give yourself options
and then if the time should come
you can avail yourself of those options
what else can i say
noah wrote in
and said david
do you think donald trump will be
indicted
and sentenced for the rest of his life
no i don't
i do believe at this point increasingly
that it is likely trump will be indicted
i don't think trump's going to do a
single day behind bars
opening that one up to the rest of you
if you believe trump is going to do
prison time any at all
write in info davidpakman.com leave a
youtube comment send a tweet
leave a facebook message respond to me
on truth central whatever
i don't believe he will do a single day
uh we have a great bonus show for you
today you can sign up for the bonus show
by becoming a member at
oh
joinpackman.com
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah all right
uh join pacman.com you can use the
coupon code big voting22 to get a
discount and i will either see you on
the bonus show or once we return
from the labor day long weekend